AMBARISH KENGHE:
Welcome to our talk.
We're going to talk
about making Google Cast
apps more discoverable.
And my name is
Ambarish Kenghe, I'm
one of the product managers on
the Google Cast and Chrome Cast
team.
And--
AMY WU: And I'm Amy.
I'm currently a product
manager on the Play Store team.
AMBARISH KENGHE: To start
with, how many of you
know about what Google
Cast and Chrome Cast is?
Cool.
Awesome.
So I'll quickly--
just to set context--
I'll quickly go through
what Google Cast is
and how the ecosystem works.
And then we'll get into
how the apps are discovered
and what you guys can do to
make them more discoverable.
So essentially, what we
have in this ecosystem is
we have two sides of
the equation here.
We have a set of
devices and we have
a set of sort of receiving
devices and sending devices.
And Google Cast is a
technology to enable
exciting multi-screen
experiences.
So essentially, what
you're able to do
with Google Cast is
you're able to make TVs
and large displays an
extension of a personal device,
like mobile, tablet and phone
that you already have on you.
The basic idea
here is that you're
leveraging the interaction
model that you're already
used to on phones,
tablets, and PCs.
The keyboards that
you're used to,
the touch screen
that you're used to.
So you're leveraging
that model to interact,
but you're still able to use
the power of a big screen
and a powerful speaker
in your living room.
On the other side
as a developer,
what you're able
to do is you don't
have to write an application
from scratch here.
For a TV display,
for example, you
don't have to create a new
deeper interaction model,
you don't have to think about
information density there.
You can just leverage the
apps that you already have,
use all that model that
you've already built,
and then just use the TV
for displaying information
and creating sound
that you need to do
from that kind of a display.
Now, what we are doing is we
are building this technology
into a variety of
receiving device.
So we've shown you
Chrome Cast-- Chrome
Cast has this technology built
in-- we announced Android
TV yesterday so Android TVs has
the Cast technology built in.
And you'll see a
variety of other devices
which will have this
technology built
into them over the next
few months and years.
On the sender side, we have SDKs
for iOS, Android and Chrome.
So if you have
apps across these,
you can easily get the
SDK and enable your apps
for a Google Cast experience.
So that's a quick overview of
what Google Cast and Chrome
Cast is.
Now we'll talk a
little bit about what
we are doing to
surface applications
that you build because users
need to discover applications
that are Google Cast enabled.
So I'll have Amy start
the discovery experiences
with Android and then
we'll go ahead and talk
about iOS and Chrome later on.
AMY WU: So the first
thing we've done
is create a permanent
place in the Play Store
where users can go and find
and browse Chrome Cast apps.
There's a couple different
ways to get there.
The first of which is in
the Play Store itself,
if you go there
directly, there's
a Chrome Cast tile
that's permanent
where you can go
and consistently
be able to find the
Chrome Cast app page.
The other way is
if they actually go
to chromecast.com/apps.
If you have the
Play Store enabled
that will also direct you to
this page on the Play Store
app.
Next.
So on this page itself, there's
a couple of different sections.
There's Featured, there's
New and then there's
More Apps, all of which expand
to a fuller page of apps
that are enabled
for Chrome Cast.
The other primary way that users
kind of browse and discover
apps in the Play Store is
through Search, of course.
And so when users search for
a Chrome Cast related content,
then they will find Cast
enabled apps there as well.
And finally, we
basically, on the store,
are always looking
for ways to create
a much more personal experience
for users so that each of them
seem content that's relevant.
One way to do that, of
course, is on the homepage.
In this case, for apps, the
surface content that we think
are especially relevant for you.
If you're a Chrome Cast owner,
for instance, in this case,
well, actually--
we know that Cast
enabled apps would be
especially good for you
so we actually insert them
on the home page as well.
In this case, the apps
for Chrome Pass section
goes to the same collections
page that you saw earlier.
AMBARISH KENGHE: And we
have, like Amy talked about
on Android, chromecast.com/apps
will automatically redirect
to the Play Store page and
we've created a special page
for Chrome Cast and
Google Cast on Android.
So you can discover all the
Google Cast apps right there.
On iOS as well, you
can just-- if you go
to chromecast.com/apps it
automatically gets redirected
to a special page that we
have then where we have apps
discovery experience.
And you get the same set
of applications there.
But in this case, you're
going to get applications
that are enabled for iOS.
If you click on
our app here, it'll
automatically take you to
the app store, and from there
you can install the
application and that
just works as it was
working for you in Android.
We just automatically
redirecting to the app store
and the app gets
installed on your device.
You can also go to the web
experience on the laptop.
Again, you're going to
chromecast.com/app which is,
again, prominently displayed
on your home screen.
You go to this experience
and, again, you
have the Featured,
New and More Sections.
In this experience if
you click on an app,
you get an option to
either go to the website
or you can install the
iOS or the Android app
onto your mobile devices
directly from this website.
So we give you a quick
overview and we sort of
announced this yesterday
at the keynote as well.
We give you a quick
overview of what
we are doing to make
apps discoverable.
We're continuing to
work more on that
and you'll see in the
coming weeks and months
that this gets more
interesting and we'll
do more things to make
apps discoverable.
Now, I want to talk a
little bit about what
you can do to make these
apps more discoverable,
help us service your
apps are better.
So how many have you
have published an app
on the developer console, on
the Cast developer console?
Awesome.
So if you've already
published an app,
I wanted you to go to the-- and
you haven't gone back there,
I want you to go back
to the developer console
as quickly as you can and enter
the information that we're
going to talk about next.
If you have not published
an application, then
through the flow we are
going to-- before you publish
the app-- we're going to ask you
to provide us this information.
So if you publish
the app, you hit
on the-- you click
on the Edit button
on your app on the
developer console
and you'll be presented
with a bunch of details.
The one that I wanted to
specifically point out
is the details about your iOS,
Android and web applications
because these are
the links that we're
going to use to [? surface ?]
your applications
in the app discovery
experiences.
So be sure that
this part is right.
And at the same time,
you want to be sure
that you don't
put in duplicates.
For example, just in case if
you have multiple receivers
for your application or if
you're publishing applications
that you really don't want to
be made public to the world,
then don't publish it yet.
Use it as an
unpublished application
on your whitelisted devices.
Once you're ready to publish,
enter this information,
publish it.
Know that once you
enter these links,
we will make them public in
the apps discovery experience
and from there users
will be able to discover
these experiences.
And also, while we're not
right now using the category
information that
you're providing,
we have three tabs
right now-- Featured,
New and More-- we
do want you to put
in the right information in
the categories drop down there.
Because in future, as we try
to categorize your applications
better, if you
have that category
there we'll be able
to do that for you.
And next, the other
thing I wanted
to point out on the
developer console
is your title and the image.
For the graphics, just go
to various experiences--
the iOS and the web especially
on chromecast.com/apps--
and make sure that this icon and
graphics is going to look good
there.
And we have specifications on
how big this graphic should be
and how it should look.
And make sure you're providing
the right information to us
there.
On Android we've already
leveraged the information
you have given to
us on the Play Store
so you already have the
graphics and description there
that we can just reuse there.
So that's pretty
much all you would
need to do in terms of
enabling the experience.
Enter this information and save
and that makes your application
public.
So that's about it.
I wanted to sort of
open it up for questions
and talk about anything
you may have there.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AMBARISH KENGHE: Sorry.
It's too loud.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Sasha from [INAUDIBLE] Media.
So by publishing
our application--
I'm sorry-- it will be
discoverable by users
through the Search, right?
If my application,
our application,
requires a mobile side-- so
it doesn't work as Chrome Cast
application at all-- and I don't
want it to be discoverable,
can I hide it?
Because our use case is, I
have my mobile application
but discover Chrome Cast.
And then my mobile
application communicates
with a Chrome Cast,
launches [INAUDIBLE],
and only that scenario is valid.
Users don't need
even to see that we
have another side
published on a Chrome Cast.
You understand the scenario?
AMBARISH KENGHE: No.
Actually I don't
understand your question.
So you're saying you have
a mobile application.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
My-- our scenario
it's live streaming,
live video streaming.
And we developed the
receiver for the Chrome Cast.
Now, that receiver we cannot
launch without our mobile
application, our own
mobile application.
There is no any other mechanism
to launch our Chrome Cast
receiver application, right?
So in this sense, when I
publish our receiver application
I don't want it to
be discoverable.
AMBARISH KENGHE: I
see your question.
So in this-- just to clarify.
We are making the
receiver public.
What we are doing is
we're making a link
to your mobile
application public.
So once you publish
a receiver, what--
in the end, the
receivers, nobody really
has links to the receivers
from a user perspective.
They don't care
about the receiver.
All they care about is
the mobile application
which will help them to
launch your receiver.
So really what this is
doing is you're providing us
links to your Android, iOS
and Chrome applications,
and then that's allowing the
users to launch the receivers.
So, yes, the receivers,
nobody really
needs to know about them.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AMBARISH KENGHE:
That's a good question.
I think that's-- right now what
we do is we do it organically
where we hunt for applications
and we look for people who have
developed interesting
applications.
What would help you
on getting featured
is we have UX
guidelines on the web.
So if you can make sure that
your app follows those UX
guidelines really well,
that's number one.
Two, you want to make sure
the use case that you have
is interesting use
case for Chrome Cast,
that makes sense for users.
And then we would discover them
as they pop up in the list.
We look at a bunch
of stuff the signals
in terms of what's
happening and how
people are using
these applications.
We're constantly on a hunt
for featured applications.
Because in the end, for
us, it's great to have
interesting applications
up there on that list.
So if you're following those
guidelines and users are
starting to use it, we'll
definitely notice it.
AUDIENCE: I haven't got a chance
to look at the Chrome Cast app
store page.
So how does the plus
one thing works there?
If I get somebody to plus
one the Chrome Cast app,
does it reflect to the
organic listing also?
AMY WU: On the Play Store?
Yeah.
If you have a plus--
so if in your circles,
one of those people
plus ones, let's say,
one of the Chrome Cast apps,
that would personal-- so,
essentially, that
would send that app
to the top of your list
because our list is basically
personalized within a collection
based on what we think--
is that your question?
AUDIENCE: Will I see, even
if I'm not a Chrome Cast
user, if I never connected my
account with a Chrome Cast,
will I still get
to see that app?
AMY WU: Oh, I see.
So if you don't have a
Chrome Cast yourself,
you won't see that
collection on the home page.
But you can still access the
Chrome Cast tile that you saw.
You can get to the
collection that way.
But because we don't
think the collection would
be as relevant for
you, we don't actually
put it on the home page.
AUDIENCE: OK.
AMBARISH KENGHE:
Other questions?
OK.
Cool.
Looks like we can all get
back to the game there.
Thanks.